ah ooh ah the [ __ ] is with this [ __ ] so
much volume
20:18 is starting with a lot of volume
in the hair
[Music]
hey what is going on YouTube now
interestingly enough I didn't want to do
this topic but because it was so highly
requested and this year I am going to be
doing a lot of videos based on what you
guys are asking of me just because we're
gonna mix it up a little bit but yeah
here we go now originally I didn't want
to talk about this because there's this
idea that if you shed light on negative
topics you're only making it bigger and
you're only making it bigger for the
people that want the most so you're kind
of feeding the trolls but this is very
important just because I've been a
concentrator now on this space for about
like 7 6 7 years now or 7 years starting
this March oh because this topic relates
to this community here let's have a
discussion on it now you guys already
heard about the situation because every
person the moment is dropped they
[ __ ] scramble to the camera was like
oh my god did you hear about it it's
[ __ ] crazy how fast people jump on
this new they were just like oh god I
gotta talk [ __ ] but yeah this video is
gonna be about that one youtuber named
Logan Paul now I've been away from the
space for a very long time
and I've always heard this name
constantly at the side of my ear I'm not
even sure that's phrase the side of your
ear but recently he did a video where he
traveled to this forest out in Japan and
as we know it as is the suicide force so
the idea behind that forest is that a
lot of people in Japan who you know that
country already has a very high suicide
rate people go there to kill themselves
it's like some serious [ __ ] the dude
being the new-age youtube vlogging [ __ ]
that he is decides to go to that forest
and then with this tour guide or
whatever you see this body hanging there
and he records it he records this this
man who decided to end his life [ __ ]
hanging there and he records it for
entertainment so as you begin to watch
the video you see clearly this guy is
still in character and his vlogging
character like holy [ __ ] bro oh man whoa
this is so of course him and his little
[ __ ] d-bag friends are laughing
they're trying to hold back there and
laugh for some reason watching the man
who just ended his life hanging from a
[ __ ] tree that I don't I don't I
don't
don't get it of course you the internet
decided to lash out at him and destroy
him
just because rightfully so the guy's a
[ __ ] piece of [ __ ] so the point of
this video isn't so much to talk about
this piece of [ __ ] white trash or his
[ __ ] dumb [ __ ] of a [ __ ] brother
cuz we already knew this we already knew
the type of content they made we already
knew the type of people that they are
and I am NOT surprised that he would do
something like this we are actually here
to talk about how somebody like this is
created there's a certain amount of
social responsibility with it when it
comes to people who watch it now
hopefully if you are watching my channel
you donât donut I said donut somehow I
incorporate donut in this again
hopefully if you're watching my channel
most likely you're not watching his and
if you are I don't even understand how
that works because half my content makes
fun of people like him people out there
are outraged their incessant send
stuffing their saying [ __ ] like I can't
believe he did that that's so
insensitive this guy's so vapid he's so
self-absorbed what the [ __ ] have you
been watching this whole time of course
he is it's so interesting because the
people that created this [ __ ] monster
are the same people that are whining
bitching and complaining about him I'm
not saying he's a dope person i [ __ ]
think the guy is [ __ ] garbage I've
been saying it since day one however I
find it very interesting that people who
put money into his pocket that
constantly grow his channel they sit
there and they act surprised so I asked
people out there who watch his content
and are surprised why how are you
surprised see we call this like moral
like selective ism this is why on my
channel like I tend to just do whatever
the [ __ ] I want because everybody has a
[ __ ] odd as morality meter that sense
of empathy and altruism those values are
slowly starting to disappear because you
only give a [ __ ] about something when it
only affects you that's it that's it and
for those of you out there that I'm
going to defend him saying that he's
young you know that young excuse doesn't
really [ __ ] work cuz he's really not
that young I the guy is a huge star he
has a huge name out there and he has a
huge voice and I don't think that I
should hold everybody up to that however
his channel is based on children
watching him
so yeah man you got a certain sense of
social responsibility that you have to
fill yeah it's not what you signed up
for and I understand it's not what I
signed up for - and I get burned for it
all the [ __ ] time but there's a
[ __ ] line that you cross that's not
even funny there's no humor in it either
that's the crazy part because here's the
thing because like when comedians do
that [ __ ] right
when comedians cross that line they kind
of take that payment they turn into
humor there was no [ __ ] humor in your
video it was just you recording a man
that hung himself from a tree and you
laughed at him and here's the worst part
of it all you're [ __ ] sorry excuse
for an apology on your little hey dear
lo gang which is the [ __ ] cornea
should ever heard in my life you [ __ ]
[ __ ] it was so funny because your
apology was essentially you talking
about yourself and how awesome you are
how you make so much content and then
because you make these everyday films
which by the way it is not a [ __ ]
film you [ __ ] hot piece of trash
how you're allowed to make these
mistakes because god somebody like me
who just brings so much joy to this
world oh god I didn't mean to I just
wanted to raise awareness shut the [ __ ]
up the funny thing is he trying to pawn
it off as oh my god I'm just trying to
raise awareness for suicide now you are
not and the fact that there are actually
people out there that believe it holy
[ __ ] you're dumb is [ __ ] raised suicide
awareness I just see no [ __ ] week for
some suicide prevention [ __ ] oh I
wonder why people like you when they
[ __ ] up you just can't imagine up in a
minute don't don't do this backpedaling
[ __ ] you're a [ __ ] piece of [ __ ]
just own up to it you guys have to
realize something too when somebody
posts a video it's edited which means
whoever edited did it in his flavor and
also with his discretion meaning that he
saw that video before put out it was
chopped up and done in a certain way he
goes hey you know what that's good I
should put it up which means there was
no remorse he only did it for the views
and even when people say that he goes oh
my god I get views like the most
self-centered [ __ ] that's not what they
mean we all know the tactic of [ __ ]
YouTube it's it's so sad it was
purposeful that was purpose and why he
put it up and it wasn't because he was
trying to help people it was because he
legit thought yo this was a [ __ ]
awesome video nobody has
I forgot to put up somebody hanging
themselves from a [ __ ] tree and on
top of that I probably think it's a
little funny
Oh [ __ ] hell man you know I'm a nice
dude now and I've always been a really
nice - but it doesn't mean that I grew
up around like really great human beings
I know [ __ ] criminals and thugs that
went that didn't find that [ __ ] funny
man
like somebody hanging themselves and
killing themselves is entertainment it's
it's odd and I guess the last point to
this that I am gonna put out is this I'd
guarantee you that after this whole [ __ ]
blows up he's still gonna get millions
of views people are still gonna love his
content people are still gonna buy into
his [ __ ] and at the same time the
same people that do are still gonna
complain about him does it make any
[ __ ] sense and that's the problem
this is somebody who has grown up
without being checked his whole life
nobody has checked this bull and I bet
you at the end of the day he's gonna do
some publicity stunt with like oh I'm
gonna donate so much money to the
suicide hotline at you know [ __ ] mean
any of that [ __ ] dude
you don't and you're gonna try to cover
your ass and then you're [ __ ] stupid
ass bad bass is gonna believe it and
just along with them I'm all honesty
they're trash to them they're trash with
you so trash mingles together so enjoy
that [ __ ]
I can't wait for his like half-assed
like real apology his quote-unquote real
apology I wonder how much money he's
gonna donate to like the suicide hotline
now we'll put this out there too
I've never really had like suicidal
thoughts so I I don't know what that
feels like I do know what it feels like
to not appreciate yourself in the field
that maybe sometimes your existence
doesn't matter
[ __ ] you know in Japan and Korea suicide
is a huge thing
it's huge out in that country man just
recently to a a very huge k-pop star
killed themselves and you you don't know
what it's like to go in somebody's head
when they when they're at the end of the
rope and they're just like this is a
solution to all my problems it's just -
and my life and then you know I saw that
video and for some reason I just saw
that person hanging cause I thought that
person was going through that same
feeling that the people that I knew went
through where they said this is it this
is this is a solution this is the only
thing that I can this is the only way I
can solve my problems
and then you had this kid sit there with
the camera and film him and pretend to
be just put on this act with the show
and then laugh at the dudes face like
huh what the [ __ ] I don't know there's
some serious stuff and like I said
before like comedians joke about
anything and everything but there was no
humor in this you literally saw a dead
body hanging from a tree in you what
even wasn't a mistake it was a
reflection of who he is as a human being
it's not a mistake and is a reflection
of who he actually is as a human being
you created that
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]